I want to add just a little more flavor
on the Trump Porter Rico insensitivity
okay in the middle of this horribly
offensive series of faux pas slope after
faux pas Trump on Twitter slamming the
mayor of San Juan who's pleading for
help this is gonna sound like a fake
story but it's all too real remember how
I told you that Trump was golfing at his
New Jersey result Resort while the mayor
of Puerto Rico was pleading for help it
turns out that Donald Trump also handed
out the trophy at a golf tournament at
one of his resorts but what did he
decide to do I guess to show deference
and caring for the victims of the
hurricane in Puerto Rico as well as in
Florida and Texas Trump chose to
dedicate a golf trophy a meaningless
symbol of privilege to the victims of
recent hurricanes in Puerto Rico Florida
and Texas here's Donald himself on
behalf of all of the people of Texas and
all of the people of if you looked today
and you see what's happening how
horrible it is but we have it under
really great control Puerto Rico and the
people of Florida who have really
suffered over this last short period of
time with the Hurricanes I want to just
remember them and we're going to
dedicate this trophy to all of those
people that went through so much that we
loved a part of our great state really a
part of our great nation can't even help
himself he has to brag I mean did you
hearing that it's terrible what's
happening in Puerto Rico but we have it
under really great control and here is a
meaningless donation of this trophy to
the victims it's sort of like dedicating
your one hundred and fifty dollar
bone-in ribeye steak to the kids in
Africa who can't afford to eat and might
die of hunger in the next 24 hours but
at least there was one person there who
disagreed and decided to have their
voice heard someone actually heckled
Trump later in the speech yelling
something like you don't you don't give
an s about Puerto Rico
I don't know that Trump not caring about
Puerto Rico is in any way unique Trump
seems not to really care about anybody
other than the self aggrandizement and
self enrichment of his own family and
also it's not Trump's trophy to dedicate
like I I mean I know I'm getting into
the weeds here but someone else won the
trophy you're supposed to give the
trophy to the person who earned it and
then they can decide
whether to dedicate it or not it's all
part of the bizarre delusions when I
heard Trump dedicated the trophy I
thought oh
Trump won the golf tournament Trump won
the golf tournament and decided to
dedicate the trophy he won no he
dedicated the trophy that someone else
had won it's sort of idiocy on top of
idiocy and I can't distinguish now
between a failed presidency and some
kind of avant-garde performance art
because really that would be a much more
logical explanation than that this is
really the person that Americans elected
to be President of the United States
talk about this with me on reddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
episode is made possible in part by
blueSky a binary there are millions of
forex traders around the world and 80%
of them lose money and I actually have
been dabbling in forex trading since I
was like 16 years old and I've lost some
money doing it and usually when people
lose money in this it is because they
either lack the appropriate knowledge
they might be relying on others auto
traders or other traders they follow
instead of themselves sometimes people
get emotional or take bigger risks than
they should or not understand or follow
proper money management rules and blue
sky binaries education course sort of
helps to mitigate every single one of
those risk factors they're a leading
financial education and tech company
focused on forex they've got senior
trading traders with real trading
experience offering a structured and
self-paced course that you can take
video on-demand online tests one on one
education sessions and access to their
community of traders are all part of
that course david pakman show viewers
and listeners can register right now to
get a free one-week trial at blue sky
binary.com slash david that includes
access to their training platform and a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics if you want to continue after
that it's $99.99 a month you can stop or
resume at any time once again that's
blue sky binary calm /div ID